the last experience I have being on set
with Brad Pit and like giving him
Direction he's looking at me like I'm
like a cone brother oh my God he took my
breath away smells good smells good bet
smells I have a bad sense of smell I'm
not going to lie masine like kind of mus
T I'm telling you first off when he
walks on set everyone like their posture
change everyone has such a sense of
purpose even the men right oh especially
the men wow so they know there's a
pecking order and this guy couldn't be
like nicer and not in like
not in a way where it feels like he's
like trying to be nice so like you say
good things about him it just feels like
that's his natural genuine like so down
to earth so cool uh couldn't say enough
good things about this man and hug him
at all did you give him a huger oh yeah
held him to is very in shape as [__]
like he's such good [__] by the way
tatted up in a way that t that's you
didn't know this and like cool tattoo
what like what I don't know like I don't
know what they are I saw him in Fight
Club but I was too busy looking at the V
yeah the V were crazy really taking any
T no get out of so he's just a badass
badass guy he's cool like he was really
like I would say the coolest guy I've
ever met wait really yeah yeah look at
his arm look at his arm that's a cool
arm
that that arm is cool as [__] look at
the he's got bracet he you know there's
some people that like own their
celebrity like they walk in a room they
know all eyes are on them and they're
comfortable with that I saw Hugh Jackman
do that once like he just walked around
he started introducing himself and he
knows everybody in the room knows it's
[__] Wolverine yeah it's you and
there are some people that you know what
I mean they they like they pretend that
they're not famous and they do that
thing like hey you doing I'm H hey but I
what are you going to do I feel like
that's like like how could you not do
that as a famous I don't know I would I
would feel lame like if I was Drake and
I like was had the attitude of like you
all know who I am like but does he
really need to be like hi I'm Aubrey to
you I think so or what if he's just like
Dave my man how are you brother I know
you know who I am guess it's different
if both of us have like if we're both
famous and he's we've like been dming
and you know what I mean but like if I'm
just like a guy like a PA on set yeah I
just think it's disingenuous is that the
word to be like what's up man like good
to see you like i' rather like him be
like what's up like Drake like I don't
know why I'm talking from the
perspective of
Drake embody
thatp so he's in the uh so he's in the
room so Pit's in the room
first off the way I meet Brad Pit yeah
how did this come together well no I met
him on set I actually just cold emailed
him what yeah really Reckless I wrote
the entire let me just finish one thing
first just know that when he actually
came on set for the first time and I
actually got to meet him for the first
time which is the first place I ever met
him was when he came on set of Dave we
were shooting a scene where like she was
like making a cast mold of my lower body
so I had to meet this man naked covered
in like slop like that's how I had to be
like hey nice to meet you yeah anyways I
knew power mov I basically I heard
through the grapevine that and you never
know how true any of this [__] is but I
just heard that like he was a fan of my
show like a friend of mine took a
meeting at his production company and
like one of his Executives was like oh
you know Brad loves Dave and my friend
relayed that information to me like
three years ago and I I stor I stored
that piece you hear that information and
are you is your first reaction like of
course the guy's got taste Brad Pit or
are you like oh my God Brad Pit listens
to me uh honest
reaction my honest reaction is a
combination of of course but also like I
don't know how true this information is
yeah not I'm never I'm not surprised
it's more just I don't know how true
this through the great mind information
is he should feel this way if he sees it
I imagine he would feel this way that's
how I
feel I love that I love that um but
anyway so we're writing I you know one
thing I really proud myself on with the
show is every season we end it in like
such a way where I think we make like
the best season finales possible and
unfortunately or fortunately like we
just constantly raise the bar so like
this season I was like how are we going
to beat what we did for the and I was
like well I had stored this piece of
information about Brad Pit like maybe we
go after Brad Pit to the point where
like we were started writing we wrote
the whole episode before hitting them
before even talking to him all my writer
room was like they were like that's
crazy like you don't even know Brad Pit
and I was like I know but like I just
feel like if we come with the right idea
he'll
why why wouldn't he do it I don't know
everyone was like all right same thing
with Rachel McAdams same thing with
Drake like at least Drake I met and he
was like yeah I love your show and I had
face tof face confirmation that it was
real with Rachel and Brad I just heard
through the grap Vine and I wrote them
like and this is not like a random
celebrity Cameo where like you see him
in a club and they're like what's up
Dave and like it's really like the
entire plot Arc of the whole season was
like resting on Rachel McAdams Brad Pit
and Dre okay uh and I didn't know really
any of them that well uh I barely knew
Drake did not know Rachel or Brad wrote
the whole episode got Brad's email from
uh from an an executive producer of the
show named Marty Bowen who who knows
Brad's manager okay got his email and I
just got to work on drafting that email
what's my email like the words of it I
couldn't even I me it's long no no no
your like what is what is he seeing in
his your name in your email is it Li's
Dicky my email I don't want to give it
out I'll tell you afterwards can we
believe it I guess yeah just
go no there's no [__]
way he went like
this I know that they that's your play
your okay so that's the email that Brad
sees and and I and he [__] opens it
he opens it and I write I write this
long ass like well-written like email
about you got to have it give it Bust It
Up just give us some phone in the other
room get I I honestly it's not that easy
to access like I've tried it's like my
phone like does a thing where it only
saves like 3 months worth of [__] like I
could probably get it but it would take
too long and I really don't I want to
leave it between me and Brad I don't
have you know what I
mean
Brad yeah you can't you can't viate
Brad's trust I didn't say we got to hear
the response it's not for you bro it's
not your opening line is everything in
the email right do you remember the
opening line to whom it make or like
dear Brad it's definitely dear Brad cuz
I know that he his response was dearest
Dave I love that um and basically I
wrote this long thing that I like edited
all week like sent to my writers like
was like what do you think of this draft
they were like well maybe like we take
this sentence out like like we literally
like worked on this EMA stead of writing
the you have to you have to it's the
most important we're like this is like
we're like shooting episode eight like
like deep like this episode shoots in
like 10 like in like two week you know
what I mean like we're like running out
of time and I'm like pushing it off cuz
I'm just like scared to face the reality
of like you know the highrisk procedure
I've taken and then like he like a few
days later he responded not in the same
thread started a new thread wow uh and
that's big I like didn't it was I I like
I it's hard to explain but like I
actually didn't understand that it was
his email in response back for like 12
hours I read this email I kind of
thought it was like junk or something
like it's it didn't cuz he didn't it was
really vague I assume his email is not
his name it's not Brad Brad pit.com so
yeah I can see how you're just like it
was hard to explain but his email was
like really short and sweet and like B
like not bizarre in a bad way like it
was like iconic it was like so it was
weird but like having not he didn't like
sign it Brad Pit he signed it BP and I
just wasn't thinking so when does it hit
you it hit me like like I saw in the
morning but like in Middle production
I'm doing all the things like you know
making I'm I I'm so spread thin and then
like I RIT it like lunch and I was like
BP and then I was like wait a minute cuz
I remember the subject line that's so
hard the subject line wait a minute I
don't even want to show yes say that
[__] my boy go go go go go it was it was
it was hm
hmmmm okay very cryptic also cryptic was
cool it was really sick like reread it
knowing it's Brad I'm like that's so
cool like it's the coolest email I've
ever I'm going to frame it I'm going to
frame the email and put it on anyways
and then even then I still didn't
believe it was real so I'm like I'm
hitting my agents like is this his email
they're like uh we're confirming it is
his email like they were like I think
he's in he's down and then like on set
it was like such a joy to be like guys
like Brad Pit is in the finale that's
unb but even then I still didn't believe
it would really yeah yeah cuz dat's got
to line up and [__] dat's got to line up
it's like at any point did you have to
move everything around to fit his window
or uh we shifted a few things yeah um
but it it man we by the way this guy
couldn't be more professional like I
design the shoot in a way to where like
if he want like it was long demanding
days like we shot it was like like an
hourlong episode that we only had Brad
for like he gave us four full days and
like we're talking like we're talking
like overnight like we're starting
shooting at like 9 P p.m. and going to
like 6:00 a.m. what would that be fee
wise Dove four days with Brad Pit can
name whatever price he wants he's doing
it cuz he wants to oh no of course he's
doing the show Millions like an a star
this doesn't
happen episode of TV is like or
something like friends yeah was is 30
years ago wow yeah that was a great
episode I got to say the most validating
moment of my life like prior to that it
was when LeBron James reached out to me
and dm' me about being a fan of the show
but like working with BR and it's a
shame that I live my life like just
trying to impress LeBron James and Brad
Pit and that's how I find the peace and
satisfaction it's not that most of us do
yeah most of let's be honest yeah but
what like him coming and then when he
finally show up on set and I was like
this is real and I get like I said like
like shooting scenes like you know you
shoot his coverage my coverage we always
started with his coverage and I got the
body double with the exact body type and
I'm like Brad like if you want to go
home and rest up like we can use this
other man's shoulder very easily he was
like never in a million years would I do
that he was like that's not how it
should be so so so real quick just for
everybody at home explain like when
you're shooting a show when you're
shooting a show yeah so let's say I'm
here and Brad is like here so if the
camera's on Dave yeah sometimes you can
do things called Cross coverage which is
there's a camera here and a camera here
at the same time that's really good for
like improv and stuff but it's not as
good aesthetically you can't like light
things as particularly to do it that way
so you're better off aesthetically
shooting one side at a time so I would
always start shooting Brad's side of
course so that way he could leave after
leave we got a body double cuz when
we're shooting over Brad onto me all we
need is his like flannel shirt and
shoulder and we had a man for that and
but he was like no sir
like he wanted me to
feel's energy when I'm giving my
performance and honestly it is true like
he that is the right thing to do and
those nerves are going to be coursing
through your veins you're talk going a
[__] Brad Pit and that's the vibe of
like the reality of the scenes we're
shooting is that like I am enamored with
Brad Pit so it will be easier for me to
feel enamored but it's an extra like
it's not 30 minutes it's like8 hours or
whatever extra that he's standing there
doing that I assume right yeah it's like
four four hours and it's like in the
dead of the middle of the night he he's
got to come back the next day and like
and he man talk about a trooper didn't
complain once like was just a joy like a
true Joy that's amazing yeah I think
it's and I think it's smart for the
super super aless guys also to do
cultural shows meaning like when I say a
cultural show I mean like it it has the
culture people are talking about it
because it makes them look cool too
right like how likable is Brad Pit that
he's a fan of the same show that you
were a fan of right and then he's part
of it and you know he doesn't need the
money he's just doing it to be a cool
guy got that much money like I think
that like TVs pay you got to like
legally give them something yeah like
it's not even like it's pretty
surprising how low you know TV pay can
be for even big-time actors he didn't do
it for the money he did it because he
loves the show and I'm so proud of that
episode and uh forever grateful to Brad
for changing my life now if you get Brad
did you have a backup guy you could
reach out to uh I definitely had but it
wouldn't have been the same and who who
who was it there was no real backup to
Brad to be honest with you like I had
people in my mind but like it just
didn't feel yeah yeah there's somebody
just tell him as Ben
Affleck no it
wasn't I love Ben I tried to get Ben
Affleck in the Met gal episode and he
like the schedule he was almost in he
yeah he was I had a great thing for V
Affleck in that and remember if you sign
up use that promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100
that means you put in a 100 you get 100
for free go to prix.com hurry up and
sign up you got a free Square now let's
get back to this episode with Little
Dicky were there any lines you wrote or
even scenes from the show that you're
like yo this can't go in this is too
crazy like this bar first off I looked
back at that line was like what the hell
was I thinking
saying crazy thing to Wild have have
like the Obamas reached out at all no
but I regret saying that cuz I like you
know I I first off I do believe that
like when you're rapping like like the
rap that I grew up on was like Eminem
Who was saying like the wild H like
hyperbole there's nothing literal
happening like and it was really just an
Ode to respect of like how great I think
she is you know what was the whole line
what was the whole line I said uh it's a
bar what did I
say was Googling it don't worry's right
now I said like I forget the first part
it was like in a year I'm a bend over
Michelle Obama
like I got to do it while I'm hot I'm
trying to get blue in Most states like
Barack which that's a good line that's a
good line and look I honestly I just
wanted you to wrap on the show at the
beginning of my career unfortunately I
was kind of like at a desperate like
pathetic place of like I got to say some
wild [__] to like go viral to like get
noticed to like have the opportunities I
want which I don't think that's
desperate or pathetic I don't know I
look at it as a little low lwh hanging
fruit Lo but I think at that point in
your life you're just trying to get
attention and you see the people you
look up to you're looking up to imagine
M and you're looking up to all these
other rappers they're also doing it so
you're like this is the genre I meant
nothing by it all I can tell you is like
I love the Obamas and like I have I have
the biggest fear I have the biggest fear
of like meeting them one day or like
working with them and then being like
what about that thing you have you met
anybody that you had a bar about no not
one person that you've you've wrapped
about you've cross pathed with well no I
I would not by the way I haven't wrapped
negatively like even that even even
saying that you are lusting over a woman
and then you meet talking about how much
I love Drake for a decade before I
actually met Drake and then so what
happens well then you know fortunately I
met Drake uh and he knew about the show
and loved it like I literally was at a
bar and like literally I turned around
he's got good taste and he's plugged in
yeah yeah so it was just you know he was
like you're just the man I want to see
like I love your show so much I watch it
all the time and I was like like I
literally I was the but he didn't go
high at Aubry he didn't need you're
right I'll tell you I was the perfect
combination of drunken High the moment I
like kind of had that I was
floating I looked unfair I couldn't have
come I know I was coming off really good
like you know what I mean like I was
loose I was like waiting my whole like
adult life for this moment but like I
really was at the perfect like level of
intoxicated to like handle it you know
and like it was like a 10-minute
conversation exchange numbers all my
friends are at this bar with me they're
like off to the side like he walks away
I turn around I go like and then like I
walk over to my friends and they were
like what happened and I was like
honestly I I don't even know I was like
floating that's great that's amaz that's
amazing have you have you flubbed a
celebrity interaction like some of you
met that you were so excited to meet
that you were just like o not my best hm
prob
uh oh man oh uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah give us that one Whatever whatever
made you up we can believe it we can
believe the name but tell us the story
let me think about it for a
[Laughter]
second he's running the numbers bro you
can
see okay
basically DJ khed okay who I was getting
in my Freaky Friday music video
yeah the way that we shot like a few
moments at the end where it was like DJ
K Ed Sheeran Kendall Jenner like I I was
in Chris Brown's Body then I switched
into like these other bodies for like 10
seconds so like we really were like
loose and like how whatever their thing
was going to be like what they said and
like so I was going I was on my way to
DJ C he agreed to be in the video to
shoot and record his line that was TB
determined so I had to I was going to
pitch him on a number of things I'm on
the way to his house and I'm texting my
director of the video I'm being like
look my dream version of what I would
want him to do is be completely
naked
and be like
I'm DJ khed like and like make some sort
of Dick joke about like whatever we
think like his dick is like and as soon
as I sent the text to I realized I
didn't send it to the director I sent it
to DJ cow oh [__] okay like
as as I'm on the way to and I've never
even met him so I'm meeting him right
now and like no response I pull up to
his house like I'm like oh my God like
[__]
like i r the doorbell if he answers the
door naked he's a legend and and and
then and at that point so he answers the
door yeah and and it's totally normal
I'm thinking maybe he maybe he didn't
even read read the text and I'm or or he
did and doesn't care I don't know but
he's acting very normal and at that
point I was like I because of that
botched interaction I bailed on the idea
of even pitching anything envelope
pushing to DJ Cal I was like let's play
it safe and Pitch him I'm DJ khed why am
I yelling which is like you know he when
he gets song He's like DJ so I was like
let's just pitch him something like that
we get up to the studio he's like so
what do you have in mind and I'm like
what I'd love for you to do is be like
I'm DJ Ked why am I yelling and he was
like H what else you got and then I like
thought he would just have accepted that
pitch and the only other pitches I have
were like dick like nude dick joke like
related type
[__] and he was like H what else you got
and I was like uh like well I was like
we could we could like make a dick joke
and he
went a dick
joke like he it felt as though he had
never heard the term the term a dick
joke keep going and I was like yeah like
you know like
like you know I'm a little Dicky like I
make jokes about like my dick being
small all the time he was like let's
just do the first
thing